[Music]
have I ever had my heart broken
oh my that is a deep are you all right
um yes yes yeah
[Music]
need me to tell you about it no I have
it you have it
well not like by relationship I guess
okay
heartbroken by losing someone before
when I was a sophomore in high school
one of my best friends died in a car
accident well she was actually her
sister was in my grade and so I was just
kind of really close with both of them
so I guess something that kind of helped
me get through it was helping her get
through it too because she was actually
in the car during the accident and I
guess it just felt like I just really
had to be there for her and be strong
for her like it's still not something
that like I'm completely over because
losing someone is really hard and but I
guess over time it gets easier but I
don't know I don't know does that make
sense absolutely make sense oh man
I is the first time that I ever dated a
guy and I was scared and it was on and
off for who
we fought on us for a while and I think
I kept getting scared and so then I kept
running away and then when I was finally
ready
he had already moved on oh we blew them
up then yeah
100 explain I think that it just feels
right now I guess that makes sense
just like it feels it is to me feels
like all the puzzle pieces are coming
together rather than before I was
looking for puzzle pieces to put
together
[Music]
in a matter of speaking yes but I don't
think that it was like I wasn't in love
so it was more like I I was infatuated
with someone that once so I don't think
I count that I think it still counts but
you make yeah
boy you did not cow I guess it is sort
of like the same feeling but I feel like
if you're brokenhearted it's like you
just know you never would you feel like
you'll never be with that person again
and it was person that I was like I
wasn't this really heartbroken but I
knew that I never
it was like a forbidden love kind of
thing and that's even almost worse
because you know it never will happen my
first heartbreak was probably when my
dad died on three he was killed in a
terrorist attack in Beirut so every year
on October 23rd I had my heart broken
because I have to watch him die up in a
building so they show on TV every year
so that is my annual heartbreak but it's
all good he wanted to be a soldier that
was from what I've learned from some of
his the guys that survived he was he had
a really good night
[Music]
I guess how I do with it is I'd really
take pride in my kids spending all the
time I can with them just because I know
he's not here so that was what I would
say to anybody whatever the situation is
that was your heartbreak just trying to
make sure you don't do it to somebody
else
[Music]
well my mom kind of left us forever
really young and stuff and
she tried to visit us
we're much older I didn't know it was
her and stuff so she's just talking to
me like if I was just like you know some
person and then when my dad like
whispered in my ear saying like oh
that's your mom I was just kind of like
I don't know this person but then when
she did leave I was really really sad
you know you shouldn't have apparently
it really does affect you I feel like I
usually break my own heart just by
getting my hopes up too high like I just
expect too much from friends or partners
and then they just could never live up
to it and so it always ends up falling
apart only one time my only relationship
I've ever had I got cancer when I was
younger and we broke up oh my god cancer
so it was a heartbreak in many ways I've
recovered but I don't think I'll have a
relationship for a while so I just
trusted she's just issues
[Music]
yep three years cancer-free I don't want
to get like emotional about a year ago
my best friend's mom died in a car
accident and it was like really sudden
so it wasn't a half fold at all like
actually it it was a drunk guy and he
crashed into her
and I was super close with that I've
known my best friend's like five years I
would always go up to the house and she
kind of felt like my mom so I think that
was like my first like real loss in my
heart like her so much and her name was
Simone and one of her like dreams or
like goals was to make like a Thousand
Cranes like one time she was like
wouldn't it be cool if we made like a
dolly cranes and so actually everybody
told everyone to make cranes and bring
them to the funeral and those are over
3,000 cranes she was like a really open
person and she was like so you guys like
when it's my funeral you know I want it
I don't want it to be sad I want it to
be beautiful and I want it to be like
like an apology
I came with the family to the funeral
mummy like walked over the hill I was
like a sea of yellow everyone was just
wearing bright yellow it was it was like
so beautiful and like happy but so sad I
had a friend once
I'm not gonna name her but uh we were
really close for like seven years and
basically some stuff happened some stuff
went down and
falling apart and I haven't seen her in
a year
and it broke my heart to see her go to
not have her in my life anymore
so I feel like that's kind of like not
really a usual heartbreak scenario but
have you ever tried reaching out no I
just feel like it wasn't a good time or
the right place
to do so you know do you have her phone
number yeah doing phone
[Music]
I mean yeah there's something new and
what what would you want to tell her I
want to tell her I think I just want to
tell her I want to see if she's doing ok
ok I know if she's like doing good in
life you want to do that yeah she might
not pick up
[Music]
oh hi
I did I feel like you might not have my
number saved anymore it's Eileen yeah hi
um sorry this is kind of just out of the
blue but I kind of just wanted to check
in and say I hope everything's going
well for you in life I don't know
[Music]
by
[Music]
I'm like shaking I don't know if I feel
good or if I feel bad it's kind of like
a mixed bag right now really why do you
say that I don't know cuz I've been
wanting to reach out to her but I just
didn't know what the right thing to say
was but I don't think there is really a
right thing to say I think in this
situation right I think the hardest part
is just making the first move
yeah maybe now like it opens the door
yeah maybe hopefully are you glad you
made the call so yeah I think I am so
you can have your heart broken in so
many different ways can you what are you
thinking of oh gosh Wow a couple months
ago I actually lost my best friend and a
mother cycle accident and I'm
but I think that was the most
heartbreaking thing like I've had
ex-boyfriends and I thought oh my god
this is love and while this hurts and it
sucks but I'm losing my best friend when
he did deserve that it was probably the
most heartbreaking day I think I've ever
heard
at first I was trying to keep myself
distracted I was going out a lot which
is not like me at all
it's drinking I was wrong people just
doing anything not to think about it but
the moments that I was alone is when it
really hit me and now I think now that I
have finally like process what happened
I'm actually able to deal with it truly
I used to be but really in depth with my
relationship of God and I've slipped
away from that because of that because
it's so much anger but now I've kind of
turned back to that so I think that's
really helping me
yes I had both like I have actually a
scar on my heart like for like a virus
that I had once and I also have a boy
but my heart was the scar my heart is
actually like I had like a cold one and
then a virus just attached to the heart
and gave me a scar and that boy was like
my best friend actually and but he's
actually wasn't my boyfriend but we were
like so close and someone he just like
stopped everything we never talked to
each other again
how long ago was that nine years ago
yeah nine years ago that's that's a long
time I think no because like I would
like to talk to him again and then I
think I would be in peace yeah sorry
stop recording
have you tried reaching out there no
well it's a long story like we had like
a lot of friends but then like in my
little I live in a little town and then
all my friends were gone
with him so I had to start again all
over again just one person with with me
my best friend I think that you deserve
and even if you can't contact them I'm
sure you'll find a way to thank you
hey guys thanks for watching another
episode if you haven't subscribed to my
channel yet and you want to subscribe to
my channel please make sure to hit the
subscribe button and a little ball next
to it so you'll get notified every time
I put up a new episode and if you really
really like my episodes and you have
some friends that you think might also
like the episodes it would mean a lot if
you shared my episodes with them as well
if you want to that's pretty much it
thank you guys again and I'll see you
next week
[Music]